protests are gripping the muslim world
over the french president's recent
defense of the right to parody religion
comes as french satirical magazine
charlie abdul whose caricatures are at
the center of the row
add fuel to the fire with the latest
front cover
now this features a cartoon of the
turkish president who's been one of the
fiercest critics of the french state's
stance on freedom of expression
ankara has called the front cover
disgusting turkish prosecutors launching
a criminal probe
in response to charlevoix publishing his
caricature the turkish president slammed
its alleged hostility towards islam
adding the disrespect for the prophet
muhammad is spreading like cancer
especially among european leaders
we ask people in paris how they see the
erdogan cartoon
personally i find it disrespectful even
if we have the right to use blasphemy
we have no right to mock religion
in these times of crisis and
international attacks on france i find
it important to reaffirm the values on
which we are firmly established in
france
the caricature is the first of these the
publication of this drawing and mocking
a religion
is dangerous because it increases hatred
it represents the fact that despite
everything humor is the most important
thing
and that erdogan in this position after
everything he has said about france and
the president of our republic
gets a nice lesson from charlie abdullah
the latest drawing with erdogan it's a
provocation
the debate over the freedom of
expression in france was brought to
prominence after the
beheading of a teacher near paris two
weeks ago
samuel patsy was murdered after showing
his class caricatures of the prophet
muhammed
his lesson had been centered on freedom
of speech as part of the french national
curriculum
meanwhile france's ambassador to
sweden's recently gone so far as to say
france is a
muslim country his remarks didn't ring
true though with the prisons we spoke to
i don't agree with the french ambassador
to sweden because we live in a secular
country
there are many communities in france one
of them muslim people which have a big
place in france
but we stay a secular country france is
not a muslim country
absolutely not it is a country of
judeo-christian tradition
and there is nothing more to say it is
really stupid france is not a muslim
country but
islam is the religion which has the most
believers here
and we can see a lot of racism in france
there are prejudices
towards muslim people earlier my
colleague
o'neil and our guests discuss the limits
of freedom of expression
you can't hold the country responsible
for what a magazine post can you
it's a private enterprise publishing
satire
in a western liberal nation i don't
think the problem is just uh charlie
hebo
and their caricatures i think it's the
institutionalization of mosques i think
it's macron's
comments that islam is in chaos islam
needs to be reformed
who is macron to reform islam who is
macron to judge whether islam is in
chaos or not
i think when it goes up to a
presidential level in france
and you have someone at the level of
macron uh
backing this caricature and making a big
fuss about it
and uh criticizing uh the state of islam
uh yeah that's that's taken very
seriously by muslims
throughout the world it's a private
newspaper and excuse me in france
all the private newspaper can make a
cartoon it's the french tradition
you can accept you can refuse if i can
say something to our turkish friend
inside this newspaper the name charlie
abdul
during 20 years i saw
caricature or cartoon against god
against jesus christ against the pope
and it's not just against muslim
this newspaper first is not the position
of the government the position
of the government is freedom of press a
lot of
muslims who are feeling they're being
directly attacked by this
it's not just seen as a clampdown on
radical
islamism how do you confront the two how
do you do that
this has echoes of a sort of clash of
civilization and value systems
i wouldn't go so far as to say it is
it is extremely difficult there are
clearly
different perspectives on the world and
and values
i think sensitivity to each other is
important and and i would say that
freedom cannot be absolute
uh in that sense religion is a very
ginger very touchy subject and
when you enter someone else's taboo
and you claim freedom of expression
but then you have a leader a french
leader again continue
to project this onto buildings you have
a french leader continue to say
islam is in chaos this really pushes the
line
there is freedom of expression and then
there's plain insulting isn't there
where does this fall normally everybody
should try to don't
offended other people for me the problem
is not muslim religion
the problem is that in my country
integration
is completely broken of course the
biggest difficulties
is to make in the same uh times freedom
for the press and uh if i can say this
not by the law okay but
distance for fellow citizens
you